bienvenidos de nuevo en este vídeo vamos
a retomar el ejercicio el cual quedó
incompleto en el vídeo pasado el
ejercicio consistía en obtener el área
que hay entre las dos curvas entre la
curva fx igual a raíz de equis y zeda x
igual a de que es cuadrada bien se
cuenta que esta área está limitada por
dos puntos x igual a 0 y por el punto
exigua la 1 yo les había propuesto la
idea de que podíamos restar áreas el
área que hay abajo de la curva fx igual
a raíz de x menos el área que hay abajo
de la curva de eje x iguales cuadrada
esa es la idea del plan que vamos a
seguir para esto vamos a utilizar el
teorema fundamental del cálculo sin
embargo esta vez ya no lo voy a notar yo
creo que ya con los vídeos pasados es
suficiente de recordar este teorema
fundamental del cálculo y lo que quiero
es que ustedes ya se lo sepan o que al
menos lo tenían presente pero bueno
cambiamos al color magenta y vamos a
trabajar con lo que nos corresponde al
día de hoy tengo que hacer primero el
área que está abajo de la función de
verdes es decir la función raíz de x por
lo tanto voy a hacer la integral de 01
de la raíz de x de x
ya con esto recuerdan que la integral o
sea la anti derivada es lo mismo que el
área bajo la curva ya esto le tengo que
quitar el área que hay entre 0 y 1 de la
función de azul que era x cuadrada de x
recuerden otra vez que la integral nos
va a dar el área bajo la curva y ahora
sí si las integrales abren sumas pues
también juntan sumas entonces en este
caso me va a ser más fácil poner todo en
una misma integral muchas personas ponen
todos una misma integral y nos va a ser
de mucha utilidad entonces tengo la
integral de 01 t quien de raíz de x
menos x cuadrada todo junto
x de x y fue muy buena la idea de juntar
todas de una misma integral porque ya lo
tengo que evaluar dos veces en uno y en
cero ya puedo hacer la evaluación
directa entonces voy a ahorrarme un paso
creo que fue bueno el haber juntado auto
de la misma integral así que vamos a
resolverlo
cuál es la integral de raíz de x bueno
pues raíz de x es lo mismo que x un
medio y si utilizamos la fórmula para la
integral es decir para la anti derivada
de una potencia de x es
de 1 a la potencia un medio más una
humedad tres medios y dividirlo todo
entre ese mismo número tres medios por
lo tanto me va a quedar ya reducido x a
la tres medios y estoy dividido entre
tres medios pero como tengo una división
de fracciones mejor de una vez lo
reduzco por dar ley el sándwich esto me
quedaría dos tercios por x la tres
medios estoy cambiando el tres medios
que pasaba dividiendo y ahora lo voy a
pasar multiplicando como dos tercios y
bueno ahora tengo que hacer la integral
de x cuadrada que es menos un tercio de
x cúbica y todo esto lo tenemos que
evaluar en donde lo tengo que evaluar en
0 y en 1 todo esto lo voy a evaluar en 0
y en 1 para obtener el área bajo la
curva que yo quiero bien y bueno pues
vamos a evaluar lo que pasa si yo pongo
el 1 en mi función a pues tengo 1 a la 3
medios que es uno y uno tuvo que es 1
entonces solamente me quedaría dos
tercios menos un tercio que es una cosa
muy fácil dos tercios menos un tercio
esconder
bien y que pase ahora si pongo el 0 pues
0 a la 3 medios de 0 0 el cubo 0 y 0 por
lo que sea 0 por lo tanto es menos 0 y
ya está ya tengo el resultado el
resultado es un tercio y es un resultado
sorprendente a mí me parece un resultado
bastante bonito y es que darse cuenta a
mí me llama mucho la atención cuando yo
vi una curva la curva a raíz de equis y
otra curva llamada x cuadrada pues
pienso en un círculo entonces yo juraba
que el resultado no iba a quedar con
algo que tuviera que ver con algún
número más raro el más extraño de
resolver y fíjense que el área bajo la
curva de raíz de x x cuadrada es ni más
ni menos que un tercio es un número
nacional un número muy conocido y que no
tienen nada dificultad es un tercio pero
en fin espero que les haya gustado este
ejercicio truculento que tuvimos en este
no esperen esperen te no tenía mucho
tiempo voy a hacer antes de despedirme
otro ejercicio me da la chance de hacer
otro ejercicio por lo tanto voy a borrar
el pizarrón y hacer otro ejercicio
corremos vamos a borrar la pantalla y a
poner otra vez la pantalla todo de negro
bien y ahora sí vamos a otro ejercicio
tenemos tiempo ok entonces tomaremos
alguna función se me ocurre tomar a fx
igual a una potencia de x algo un poco
más difícil voy a tomar x a la quinta
entonces fx va a ser igual a x elevado a
la quinta y como se ve la gráfica de
esto vamos a graficar una vez estés ni
ejes de lasieso me dejes de la sf de x y
x
aquí bien bien me quedo muy muy bien mi
línea y este es mi eje de las x y la
gráfica de esto es como una parábola
pero que crece muy muy muy rápido se dan
cuenta es algo así y del otro lado
también es algo así crece muy rápido es
una función que crece demasiado rápido
este es mi eje de las x este es mi eje
de leyes y bueno casi siempre estaba
buscando el área bajo la curva pero qué
pasa ahora si no quiero el área bajo la
curva
qué pasa si yo quiero el área que esté
sobre la curva cómo va a ser sobre la
curva ahora te van a ver siempre he
buscado el área que está bajo la curva
pero esta vez lo que quiero es el área
sobre la curva delimitado por una línea
por esta línea ahora le ponemos nombre y
yo lo que quiero es el área que está
debajo de esa línea y entre en curva efe
es igual a equis quinta bueno supongamos
que esta línea es corta en el eje de las
10 en 32 bueno entonces cuál va a ser la
función que me describa esta línea recta
si yo les digo que esta línea recta es
una recta constante y 32 entonces cuales
esperen creo que es decir la respuesta
cuál será la función que tenga esta
línea recta apoyarles la respuesta a la
función va a ser eje x igual a 32
entonces vamos a escribir lo que x igual
a 32
que de x 32
bien y como la vez pasada lo primero que
me tengo que preguntar es en qué puntos
corta mi recta a mi función
efe es igual a xq piqué pues son esos
dos puntos y bueno como lo hicimos
también la vez pasada pasa que esos
puntos lo que hay que hacer es igualar
las dos funciones entonces x quinta es
igual a 32 x es igual a sin changos no
ya me equivoqué de nuevo porque estos
pero ya se dieron cuenta ni gráfica está
mal ya desde mi gráfica está mal está
esta no es la gráfica de x quinta esta
es la gráfica de ya sé voy a ponerle el
valor de x quinta y así soluciona todo
el problema el valor absoluto de x a la
quinta y ahora si mis dos puntos de
intersección son x igualados y menos 2 y
mi gráfica si se va a aparecer esta
gráfica
sí porque x quinta iba para abajo en los
negativos y si yo le pongo en valor
absoluto pues va para arriba y ahora si
los dos puntos donde se intersecta es en
x igual a más 2 y en menos 2
bien tropilla resolví el problema el
error del problema perdón perdón perdón
a ver entonces ahora sí ya tengo esto y
pasa que yo hablar entre las dos curvas
pues utilizó el teorema fundamental del
cálculo y como utilizó el tema
fundamental del cálculo pues yo lo que
quiero es la integral de quien de menos
2 a 2 de la función que está arriba que
es la función que está arriba pues la
recta es la que está arriba entonces va
a ser de 32 ya esto le tengo que quitar
híjole la función al valor absoluto de x
quinta y esto se ve horrible de x
entonces
entonces que haré ya sé ya sé qué ocurre
la idea mejor voy a hacer un poco de
trampa y solamente voy a sacar la mitad
la mitad del área que yo quiero darse
cuenta que esta área que estoy
coloreando de morado es lo mismo es lo
mismo que el área que ésta no coloreada
de morado por lo tanto si yo solamente
sacó el área que esta colorida de morado
y la multiplicó por 2 ya cabe pero el
área que está demorado es lo mismo que
la integral de 0 a 2 de 32 - x quinta
todo esto por de x ya ver si va a ser
mucho más fácil que yo divida las áreas
y poder resolver mi problema original
pero bueno vamos a resolver la integral
de integrales 32 x menos equis sexta
entre 6 y esto evaluado de 0 a 2
bien pues vamos a evaluarlo 2 x 32 64 2
elevado a las 6 64 también entre 6 y en
cero pues es cero en se cuenta que 32
por 0 - 0 entre 60 y bueno pues aquí
está mi resultado 64 menos 64 sextos
esto es lo que yo lo que yo tendría que
resolver para obtener el área de
solamente una
parte del área que yo quería de la mitad
del área que yo quería
es decir que si yo quisiera sacar toda
el área que yo tenía en el problema
original tengo que multiplicar esta área
por 2 es decir 128 menos 128 sextos y
bueno si se dan cuenta podemos
factorizar un 128 128 que multiplica a
uno menos un sexto o sea 128 por cinco
sextos aquí está mi respuesta a lo que
sea que sea esto es 128 por 5 lo que sea
ya tengo ahora si mi respuesta del área
que yo quería sacar así que nos vemos en
el siguiente vídeo